our friend Nigel farage
guy I really like leader of brexit
he gave that great speech at the
European Parliament
where he's got the Union Jack he says I
came here some years ago I said Britain
was going to leave the European Union
you all laughed at me well Who's
Laughing Now Nigel farage great cigar
guy great conservative leader
so I'm not that long ago at CPAC
Nigel is facing some real problems back
in his own country namely
they won't let him have a bank account
I got a phone call a couple of months
ago to say we are closing your accounts
I ask why no reason was given I was told
unless it would come which would explain
everything the letter came through and
simply said we are closing your accounts
we want to finish it all by a date which
is around about now
I didn't quite know what to make of it I
complained I emailed the chairman a
Lackey phoned me to say that it was a
commercial decision
which I have to say I don't believe a
single moment so I thought well there we
are I'll have to go and find Eddie from
Bank I've been to six uh no seven Banks
actually
um ask them all could I have a personal
and a business account and the answer
has been no in every single case without
a bank account you effectively become a
non-person you don't actually exist it's
like the worst regimes of the mid 20th
century be they in Russia or Germany you
literally become a non-person and you
don't anymore you did in the past but
you don't anymore actually have a right
to be entitled to a bank account
you did in the past but you don't now
meaning it's not just the leftists who
grow the big government who are coming
for you and who are threatening your way
of life sometimes it's even the
deregulators who are ruining your way of
life because in this case Nigel is not
being oppressed by his government he's
being oppressed by the free market he's
being oppressed by corporations he's
being impressed by Banks who are saying
because you are politically
controversial by the way how's he
controversial he's just a normal guy who
said that Britain should be Britain and
not have to tailor their entire Society
over to the whims of people in Germany
and France
for saying that
for being in any way kind of
conservative Nigel doesn't get to have a
bank account if you think it's just him
you think it's just going on in the UK
or it's just going on to a big political
leader like Nigel farage you were
mistaken there is a major effort
underway being pushed by big voices on
the stage of the world economic foursome
to bring this kind of control and
Punishment to you which we'll get to in
a second first though how's your health
care do you want to check out maybe
Samaritan Ministries right now go to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care how's it
working out for you if it's working out
perfectly great okay cool if not listen
closely because I have a solution for
you a Biblical solution called Samaritan
Ministries Samaritan Ministries is a
community of Christians paying one
another's medical bills it's affordable
health care sharing and because it's not
Insurance there are no restrictive
networks here's how it works when a
medical need arises you choose the
health care provider that is right for
you and have a say in the treatment you
receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries they will notify
fellow members to pray for you and send
money directly to you to help you pay
those bills it could be more affordable
than what you are paying now and if it's
the right fit you can join anytime even
today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles Canada
w-les that is Samaritan ministries.org
Knowles right now go to hallow.com it is
clear that the left is giving up their
morals into any Common Sense there's no
better time to build a daily habit of
prayer and meditation building a habit
of prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the United
States it's helped lots of people
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you to download the app for free at
hello.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year one of the only podcasts I listen
to magnificent podcast available on the
Hallow app for brief daily read things
and Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and even some
world-class athletes with Halo you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions using
Halo to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community
ultimately we learn how to become better
individuals in spite of today's broken
world and strive to become more like
Christ in our daily lives
download hello.com Knowles get an
exclusive three months free three months
absolutely freehello.com Knowles the
libs are not only trying to take away
Nigel farage's bank account and ability
to engage in the economy they're coming
after yours
eswar Prasad is a senior professor of
international trade policy at Cornell
ivy league university senior fellow at
the Brookings institution major
center-left liberal Think Tank formally
worked as the chief of the international
monetary funds financial studies
division here he is on stage at the
world economic Forum panel in China
discussing
how they're going to control your money
the one final note I will make is that
if you think about the benefits of
digital money there are huge potential
gains it's not just about digital forms
of physical currency you can have
programmability you know units of
Central Bank currency with expiry dates
you could have as I argue in my book a
potentially better and yeah some people
might see it on a darker world where the
government decides that units of central
bank money can be used to purchase some
things but not other things that it
deems less desirable like say a munition
or drugs or pornography or something of
this sort and that is very powerful in
terms of the use of a cbdc
so this is coming this is coming here
soon
and
if you're like me if you're not just an
arch hardcore libertarian if you're a
little more conservative
then you'll listen to this and you'll
say well you know what in principle
I don't think that money should be
permitted to be used for certain
purchases
and in fact our law today reflects that
you're you're not allowed to go purchase
drugs at least in normal cities you're
not allowed
at least According to some laws that are
no longer really enforced you're not
allowed to go purchase pornography in
certain places that's always been the
case in American history and that's good
the mechanism for control was a little
bit weaker
and a little bit less subject to capris
but then you heard that that third thing
they mentioned there porn yeah I don't
think you should be able to buy porn
drugs yeah I don't think you should be
able to buy illicit drugs obviously
ammunition
well hold on a sec we have a second
amendment in this country
we have more guns in this country than
people we have a natural right to
self-defense
you're telling me now your art you're
broadcasting this before you even get
the digital currency your your
telegraphing that you will
use this new technology to stop us not
from engaging in Vice which in principle
I have no problem with
but to stop us from engaging in virtue
to stop us from exercising our natural
rights which derive from the natural law
coming here soon folks unless we stop it
as a matter of prudence even if you're
not opposed to a digital currency as a
matter of technology or
political morality
prudentially
practically speaking this will be used
against conservatives they're going to
do exactly what they're doing to Nigel
to us boy what a great clip that was
make sure that you subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel ring
that Bell
see you next time